Hey, I'm Jad Abumrad, I'm Robert Krulwich. This is Radiolab. Our topic today,
choice and human destinies. Yeah.
With the way we are is that the way we're going to stay are very nicely put.
Yes. In the last section we were talking about baboons and their propensity to
serious change, which isn't maybe or maybe not. We don't really know. Yeah.
We'll know in a thousand years. Well let's switch our ape.
We'll go to Oregonians,
which is a rare subset of human beings to set it up.
We were thinking a lot about um, small groups on this show. You know,
cause that's what we are. We are a small group primates.
That's the phrase that sometimes you use to describe as humans.
And it's a phrase that can carry some negative connotations.
As in we evolved in these small groups that we are predisposed to be small
minded. No small is not always a bad thing.
I'm gonna tell you a story now that's a small group story. It's a,
just as a warning contains a moment or two.
That's a tiny bit graphic but we hope you'll stick with it cause it's a really
cool story. Takes place in a small town like really small,
the kind of town where you can dial the wrong number and still have a
conversation cause you know everybody. So tell me where we are and,
and uh, downtown Silverton. Uh,
essentially our downtown is not changed since the late forties, early fifties.
Oh yes it has. But we'll get to that. This is stew Rasmussen.
He is our main character.
And a little while back stu gave myself and producer Aaron Scott a tour over the
theater on the corner of the old hardware store on this corner,
this tour of his favorite place on earth, Silverton, Oregon,
which is about 40 miles from Portland.
It's about 40 years from Portland actually.
It's the town I grew up in and this is my image for what I want silver and gold
to be, you know,
I rode my bicycle down the street and king to the hardware store to going,
we're doing goodness. Is that happen to you?
A lot of people just honk and wave all the time. It's a small town.
Everybody knows man, if it were up to to this town would never change.
It would stay frozen in that quaint Norman Rockwell candy coated image from his
boyhood. The weird thing though is it,
that image in his head would probably never have [inaudible] included a guy like
stu at least do as he is now.
And if this is a show about change, here is the story money, pretty radical,
bit of change where you wouldn't expect to find it. Speaking of which,
can you describe where we are and what we're looking at while we're standing in
front of the palace theater on the corner of Oak and water street,
this is one of those gone with the wind theaters with the big marquis and the
bulb lights and everything built in 1935 and then continuous operation ever
since staples out some keys and opens it up, but starting to get really cold.
He suggested that we do the interview here in the town's only theater.
Even smells like a guild at h theater,
which at 1:00 PM still smelled like popcorn from the previous night and was
filled with nothing but 200 empty red velvet seats.
Not what you expect in a small town theater. Oh, this is beautiful.
Yeah. Okay. See you later. Okay. Thank you. You'd loved ourselves at right here.
What do you think? [inaudible] seats in the house. Right in the minutes.
And pretend we're watching the movie of your life
while there is a dull movement. Hardly.
So the movie of stew begins in 1975 he's 27 and he's in a theater just like
this. No moment in my life was when the rocky horror picture show came. Yeah.
[inaudible]
STU is in the projectionist booth cause that's his job. He's changing the rails.
And at some point during one of the musical members,
he glances at the screen and it was like, oh, what was the, what was the,
Oh here was this movie with a guy in drag onscreen.
Just a fleet. Transvestite is a sweet,
transvestite trained sectional friends, sexual Transylvania.
Those are words that I've never heard.
Alright, watch that again. And again,
fast forward 10 years. Do you now owns the theater?
Just like his dad had before him. He's an upstanding member of the town.
He's on the Silverton city council.
Then on the library board and then [inaudible] he starts to transform and
everyone will tell you it began with the nails.
I think I probably started having my nails done in 94 or 95 and it started out
with very masculine nails without Polish and square ends and then slowly grew
them out and then I went into what I considered a masculine nail color of blue
and then he says he gradually started to paint them red and then he put acrylic
tips. Just got longer and longer. This was the first test. Did the community,
Hello Lori. Good evening sir. How are you? It's,
I would be at the theater taking tickets,
be dressed as usual and his plaid shirt and jeans.
His hand would come out for their tickets and
the heel are those, you can't miss it. And you know you had a long fingernail.
Hello. That's Dennis [inaudible] time. Silvertone Ian,
one time when I had to give him my ticket and that's Megan salvo. She's 17.
And he ripped it and like his nails like went down the palm of my hand and just
gave me the chills. Yeah,
probably his nails were the first thing most people notice.
Cal Palmer veterinarian and city councilman born and raised here in Silver Lake
was there talk was Oh people sitting, oh definitely talk.
But it happened so gradually, which is something you hear again and again.
It happened gradually, you know, first it was the nails and, and then uh,
at some point in time he changed the focus of the movie theater and was really
making a game attempt to get new releases and down in the theater and do
frequently, you know, when there was a theme kind of movie,
he would get into costume. My name is Ken Hector,
former mayor of a sort in Oregon.
And very often the costume would be female attire.
This is step two of Steve's very careful transition according to everyone we
spoke with for years after the nails. He would quote,
promote that week's movie by dressing up or one of the new star wars movies was
out and it wasn't a coincidence.
He was dressed as queen on the dollar. I love you.
Whatever name is from the movie. Years ago,
you remember some years ago there was a movie called my big Fat Greek wedding.
That's John, Bob, also a lifelong silver Toni.
That whole day he wandered around town in a wedding dress.
The complete with the veil. That of course got everybody talking. You know,
a lot of people laughed about it. I don't think people put it together with um,
this is Linda web. Um, she's a registered nurse. Sexuality,
transgender or any of those things.
I think we thought he was just dressing up to go along with this. Uh, Yup.
With his movies. There was clearly a,
let's go by the movie theater tonight cause we've got to know what
students wearing the, for Stu, this was just the beginning of something. He was,
he wasn't just clowning around. When did your gender complexities begin?
In probably 14 or 15.
I think I was a shy young man and interfacing with girls.
My mother was a bit strange on on that in that girls were evil and they would,
no girl was good enough for her son and Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah.
So did you date at all? Not until I was out of high school.
So girls were kind of scary. It sounds like girls were scary. Yeah,
well everybody else went on dates.
He says he would build computers from scratch.
And even today in his basement you'll find an entire electrical shop.
I'm like, God, fun stuff. RF generators, spectrum analyzer, project analyzer,
other logic, analyze it. In any case,
two says the best that he can explain himself. Gender-Wise,
it's just to say that when he looks in the mirror,
he likes himself better when he's dressed as a woman.
I don't know how to describe it. It's just, um, I can't understand it.
I mean, some people like to dress up and look like a cowboy or a lumberjack,
whatever. You know,
it's your mental image of yourself that you look in the mirror and you like.
So after the nails,
after dozens of episodes of social example cross-dressing,
Stu took the next step. He began to perform some experiments,
like he would go to the lumber yard just to get some stuff,
couple of pounds and nails or something.
All the while he would be wearing a padded bra under his flannel shirt just to
see what would happen should this for you. It was like a test.
It was like a calculated test. Absolutely gauge if it was possible,
if I could survive with breasts.
So when he was 52 he drove into Portland, visited a doctor,
put him to sleep and the doctors made two small incisions and under each breast
about an inch and a half or two inches long and they pulled back the skin on
each side,
slid in and uninflated balloon and then pumped it up with water until the skin
was stretched to the point that it was almost transparent.
[inaudible] that sounds very painful. Was it? Well, I was asleep at the time,
but when he woke up he was a different man because he now had several pounds of
new stuff hanging off his chest. What were you thinking at that moment?
I was thinking, what have I done? It was like,
there's no going back.
I can remember being in a Max place downtown at a table and uh,
he was coming across the street with his breasts prominently showing,
and it was the first time any of us realized that he had actually had surgery
and one lady was going, Oh look, look. And the other lady was going, don't look,
don't look. Or You'd see stu going across the street and Oh my God, look,
it's too, my God, what is he do? It's just sort of shocking.
There was a buzz around town. Was it a situation where he [inaudible]
walk by and then heads would turn, hushed voices would ensue? Yes.
Basically, this is Victoria sage stews, longtime girlfriend.
They've been together for 36 years.
So we would be walking in our local goodwill and we'd be a few miles away from
each other. And I would hear that used to be Steve Rasmussen,
like he had changed somehow.
His is trying to fulfill that body image. He's gotten his head,
but he's also going to in way asked you to adjust your body image if your mate,
has that been difficult?
Hm.
No. Okay. No, I'm sorry.
If you want to get kinky about it, Amanda, which is kind of cool,
Huh?
Okay. Did, uh,
was there ever any concern there was for me? Um, not so much for Stu.
I think partly because he didn't hear as many whispers as I felt I did,
but I was concerned for the theater business. Not without reason.
A lot of kids in the town stop coming to the theater because their parents
wouldn't let them.
Ticket sales took a hit and it wasn't long before pickup trucks full of teenage
boys would drive by the theater yelling slurs. Oh,
I don't know that I go so far as well. Yeah, I guess, I guess
[inaudible]
Faggot is a slur I guess.
So you get to this point in the sped up movie narrative of Stu,
this point right here where even though he took it so slowly and was so careful,
it's still easy to imagine things turning up.
I don't know. What was that movie about? The boy that was a, you know,
drunk and beat to death because he was gay in a small town in the Midwest.
You know what ways does your shepherd yeah, might be a little extreme,
but according to Linda Web Silverton's not so different from Laramie,
Wyoming where Matthew Shepard lived. It's a small town, very traditional,
very conservative. You know, you get a lot of rednecks in silver,
and so Dennis Bean puts it, so it's not crazy to expect the worst,
but here's the surprise. Give me a call. Right. And the whole reason. Yeah.
And we
came here to silver January 5th,
2009 for the worst. It did not happen.
There was no redneck rebellion. In fact, the opposite happened.
Something historic. Yeah. After me. Hi. Hi.
On January 5th, 2009 the town of Silverton elected stu mayor.
How did the city of Silverton Marion County for congratulated
it has elected the nation's first openly transgender mayor,
nation's first openly transgender mayor. This was a return last year,
this election take to do resinous and forcing slide as openly trans ginger as he
runs his hometown in heels.
And he goes, this is in fact the sound of Stews,
four inch heels pounding on linoleum as he goes to a city council meeting.
Hello Harold. Couldn't be better. How are you doing? Good now,
call us, you know, city elitist or whatever,
but a mayor and a plunging v-neck sweater and a black miniskirt.
Not what you would expect any tiny, conservative Republican town.
So we wanted to know, you know, why did this happen here? Wow.
So producer Aaron Scott and I walked around town for a couple of days and we
interviewed dozens of people, including a guy named Ken Hector,
who stu beat out for mayor. He's a conservative Republican.
Definitely not one of Steve's big fans.
It was just a difference in philosophy about, I don't want to sound pretentious,
but you know, as a mayor,
I think there's certain expectations about professionalism that you should
exhibit.
He would come in with a tight clinging top with cleavage down to here that
you're almost pointing at your belly button there a little bit higher. Come on.
You know when you're at the council meeting,
show some dignity here and just dress in the appropriate attire for the
occasion. Can't even try to get the city council to impose a dress code on stew.
But when we asked them, you know,
are you surprised that the town has embraced stu and even gone so far as to
elect a mayor? He said, no, not in this case. You know,
stu is a rarity in that. You know,
there's a lot of people in this town who were extremely religious,
very conservative people were at a stranger who came into town suddenly,
I'm sure that the support and perception might've been different,
but you're talking about a native son who grew up here
and he said, people look, your folks do runs the only theater in town.
So he's out there every weekend standing out in front of the palace theater,
taking tickets. Everybody knows him. Not only that,
back in the day he used to be the cable guys.
So he's literally been in everybody's homes.
He's still the guy you call if you have trouble with your computer.
So it might sound strange to you, but it's really not.
And that is when it hit me actually under the right circumstances.
A small town can be like the most progressive place on earth.
[inaudible]
and it's exactly because everyone's all up in your grill.
You were forced to know people. Like for instance, how long have you known sue?
Oh my goodness. I grew up with Stu. I mean we, um, I remember when stu,
it's like an alter boy. The church is my brother. This is Susie.
Seamless retired t-shirts. Yeah, his parents and my parents were friends.
Like a lot of folks in Silverton,
she is known stu for so long and then in so many different contexts that you
can't do that New York thing with him where you like you see someone on the
sidewalk and you size him up instantly and thinking freak no to her.
He's way too complicated for that, you know,
to her he's do the altar boys do the computer games? Yeah,
I probably would call it a geek to do the city council, man, let's do the mayor.
Or it's just too just too,
just, just do whatever that's him. You know, go on about your business.
Yeah. To be clear, a lot of the
people we talked to these facts,
some of the same folks who said yes dues just to,
are still not happy about the situation. No. I mean,
I don't think God's across dresser. They either felt it was morally wrong.
As in the case of this minister Tom Smith in Genesis one 27 says,
so God created man in his own image. In the more,
some folks like Linda Web's husband. John just felt like he takes it [inaudible]
it's right there. It's in your face. He dresses Kinda like a streetwalker.
You feel that that's confrontational? I do that.
Most of the people who had objections,
it was a little more nuanced and it went something like this. Well, I,
I personally did not vote for him for mayor because I didn't feel it was a good
idea to have someone that looked like that representing us.
But on the other hand, he is a good man and he's got this town at heart.
In other words, according to John Bach,
the problem really isn't stu or the town. So the way he, it's the outside,
all those people out there who are going to hear about stu
and then judge them,
which is what makes November 25th, 2008 such an interesting day.
Steve had just been elected mayor,
he'd squeaked it out by about 400 votes but he hadn't yet been sworn in when a
group of Christian extremists from Kansas showed up in town and started marching
up and down main street yelling at people and at one point they even unfurled
and American flag put it on the ground and stepped on it just to show how
offensive
they found students. It's our duty to come out here and preach to everyone
is the scariest thing these folks hate stu.
Cause they will not by any means warn him about to send this,
taking him to hell. Okay,
so one pleasant and then bringing up signs that key things like a god hates
overtake, God hates your mayor. God hates fags. Your pastor is a horn. Yeah.
It's an abomination for a man put on a woman's clothes and to be the opposite
sex. If he folks from the town decided, yeah,
let's just start a counter protest. We stood, uh,
across the street from these people by and large, just a few guys. At first, no,
earlier,
someone had suggest all the guys ought to dress up as girls and all the girls
had to dress up. These guys. Yesi Davidson said, isn't this a reaction?
Was here. Right? But there he was in a dress. I had a great time.
We, Betty new breast [inaudible],
but that really actually was the first time he says that at first he and the two
or three other guys who had on women's clothing felt a little weird.
But then
people just started coming and this just amazing of a couple of hundred people.
I mean men dressed like women, women just like men.
Some of the people that I sat down there were surprising because I had labeled
them in my head is conservative and people drive by people with signs.
God loves, so God loves stew. With the costumes,
the town was really alive in the crowd, just kept getting bigger and bigger.
Who were you? What were you thinking at that moment? From what I understand,
you were standing off to the side just watching what was going through your
mind. Yeah, well,
honestly I tried to discourage people from even giving them the time of day
saying, don't give them any attention.
I couldn't get that to happen. They were so angry and
they came out 200 people, men in dresses,
grandmothers, babies. That's,
it's just amazing that that was the town that wasn't me.
[inaudible] sorry,
I get a little emotional.
That must've been a turning point for you.
The biggest one? Yeah.
[inaudible]
before we go to break, I just want to give props to Aaron Scott,
who did a huge chunk of the reporting for that piece in co-produced it with me.
We'll be right back.